[Musica]
benvenuti benvenuti e cribari a questo
nuovo unboxing format forse più forte
che ho sul canale siamo oggi qui limiti
per riuscire ad e scatolare un altro
pacco fantastico che quello l'altra
volta era fantastico ma questo sarà
ancora di più
ricordatevi che ogni volta che le
scatole porco di esso spostato la gara
mi pare il cane sposta alla camera
quindi i ragazzi siamo ad un lato
episodio del unboxing e oggi come tutti
gli episodi the scateneremo in qualche
cosa che io ancora non conosco pescato
liamo che è meglio a me il pacco di oggi
un qualcosa di meno
vivo questo già meglio azioni grosso va
bene allora grazie mille aiutante della
fragile
speriamo di no a me l'attrezzo del
mestiere le forbici le forbici dove lei
mese ecco quindi ragazzi visto che oggi
ho qui un mio amico direi che possiamo
chiamare il nostro aiutante che ci
accompagnerà per questo video quindi per
rullo di scatole aiutante si va beh ma
se eccomi mancarmi la gamba grazie molto
gentile valle aveva fatto avere la va
bene speriamo che non sia del cibo
scadente che non ti tocchi perché
secondo ma infatti il gioco oggi è io
apro e dare a te
ok quindi se così fosse cibo e ma fosse
roba buona
vediamo bene poi ho sempre l'onore di
the scatolare il la magnificenza
no per maniero maglie alte quello che ho
visto il primo è uno zaino ma sfuma
rapidissimo comodo dai netto
guardamiglio guarda sdraiati sdraiati
simpatico cosa dici dove avete trovato
st provato incredibile è fighissimo
sono contento che innanzitutto non sia
roba da mangiare secondo sono tutte e
tre si è roba figari culo è va bene sono
un sacco di cose mi dovrei aiutare tour
da quello che vedono come pacco
successivo direi di andare su questo mi
sembra decisamente allora credo che
siano orecchie per essere riconosciuti
meglio a scuola quindi le chiamerei
cuffiette andiamo antislavo perché
queste quattro elementi nessuno sa che
c'è delle cuffie ovviamente dopo come
orecchie capito presto bene cioè per la
spiego durante i compiti in classe
voi chiamate il vostro amico che sta a
casa con l'influenza con libero davanti
e mettete l'auricolare bluetooth o
attaccata e questo poi durante il
compito copiate il volo vi dice le cose
che mi sente lo sentite e tanto non si
vede che avete le cuffie perché è
mimetico meeting next all in e arcade
machine questo è bellissimo velo piazza
da qualche parte sicuro l'attenzione
avrebbe fatto subito no ma sto male solo
andare i giochi tagliate male che bel
passaggio chi fa 19 zio
si ringrazia sinceramente ci sono
riuscito a segnare l'italia passa in
vantaggio sono male le orecchie
però basta arrivo fabio birreria cara
come mia madre visite degli amici poi
dice che è solo tempo ecco andiamo
avanti a me ispira tantissimo questa
cosa che non ho riconosciuto per niente
cos'è c'è un key o no storia cadevo
rimuovere la palla d'andata la ti stai
certo che riguarda come aveva già fatto
gli uomini le cose di mille anni
our hans no no adesso andata ci aspetta
magari non ti ricordi cosa devi fare
3 move the ball crown the bottle a sport
grazie alla norma i nervi solo un botto
ma lo vedo lo vedo che trova come il
dentino da latte quando balla slater e
adatta però ciò che ha fatto due ore ma
abbiamo stilato e amico intelligente ci
ha messo un po per promesso se io andrò
era ben sa neanche che mai uno score
finale ci ha messo un vostro vicino si
tocca
passiamo al prossimo ragazzo un teddy
bear tratti ho 23 anni ma e lui no
guardate che metto un pazzo tenero ma
cos'è l'isola è bellissimo quando poi vj
smette di fare primis è veramente figus
tolosa non mai trovare una volta questa
cosa al rolex zio trasforma prima non ho
mai visto trasforma la merita però
perfetto bellissimo abbiamo fatta si
gira anche la testa il saccarello l'ex
va bene grazie per avermi regalato
questo orologio che mi metterò stasera
per le cene di gala con me o due che mi
incuriosiscono uno grosso e uno meno
i due pacchi grossi quale vuoi però
quello meno quello che sei toccando dai
sei pronto ai camper di breaking bad
però ha però terrore quando abbiamo
perso ma poiché per cucinare la messa
quindi con me
[Musica]
è un brucia incenso brucia l'incenso ed
è un maledettissimo camper di rete nei
commenti se anche voi che vedete il fumo
che non c'è o non c'è il fumo perché non
abbiamo inciso zio perché quello che ha
fatto il pacco ci ha portato del pil e
già non ci ha portato vincenzo ho fatto
un pacco possiamo andare avanti
perfetto come prossima cosa io vorrei
passare all'altro parco di oggi che
sarebbe è un po che non hanno aspettato
sto male questo non aspetta sempre un
sogno da piccolo
c'è una cosa che da piccolo io ho sempre
desiderato e non è ormai parte della
fuoco e molto e la betulla lanci ed esce
veramente il pokémon quando lance lavoro
è veramente così nel 2018 movimentato
bar che è male se vuoi la super passione
e abbiamo quasi l'ultimo palco da questo
di cos'è ovvero il penultimo parco
questa così guarda
quindi secondo me anche la sola ottime
cose j
l'ultimo fattori oggi hovercraft che non
so che cosa sia sarò questa tizia qua
palesemente una parrucca e lui no cos'è
un rino non so dove c'è un dado ci sono
così da costruire sarà un gioco dei
futuri sting villingen malan si game
quindi il gioco futuristico di
costituzionale minecraft solo over tra
credo che ci sia questa piattaforma dove
tu tieni questo qui che rimane in
sospeso perché è calamitoso che figo e
tu lì ci devi mettere le costruzioni del
primo che lo fa cadere è un deficiente
per trovare quindi un pezzo per uno tipo
genga se allora devi tirare un dato si
sondato ieri non è uscito uno a uno e
metto io è arrivato uno è uscito ho
tirato uscito uno mi dimetto un pezzo se
ti esce 2 nelle di mettere due se tsr se
questo qua devi rimuoverne uno perde chi
e quando mette il pezzo può accadere
come jane è quello di come io e anni
mario dai che uno allora il primo pezzo
che metto è questo r è uscito r va bene
allora daremo i primi muovere festa sì
ma devi more sei mica tu hai già perso
no ma devi fare attaccare quelle sim ad
attaccare usa facciamo quindi ritirare
siamo facciamo mai al 12
va bene non farei mai un ingegnere
nell'architetto però su inizi ho perso è
stato molto bello meno male che non ti
sei giocato quest'anno andata bene
questo è che station cinque ragazzi il
pacco è finito e ringraziamo chi ha
creato il passo si è creato grazie
grazie grazie alla land lina di valenti
valentina che la sul palco
spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto
ci siamo un po messi in costume quale è
stato molto difficile perché come come
tela criterio e credimi allora
innanzitutto quando ho visto bene in
mente la prima cosa che ho detto voglio
fare questo però se mi beccano sembra
questa cucina metamfetamina quindi non
potevo farlo però oggi a quei ragazzi
questo era il finale della boxing dei
giochi strani
questo in teoria comunque doveva essere
mio però non è un regalo grazie lo nevio
ringrazio tempo e per quanti ci fate a
questo video questo è il tuo regalo per
aver partecipato vorrei darmi un cane
però tutto il resto rete nemmeno io mi
dispiace che alla fine non sono riusciti
a cucinare un po di incendi incenso
vincenzo nel camper prove quello lo
faremo più avanti però insieme 100
ragazzi cosa è servito durante mi piace
anche vanità ciò che come la descrizione
senza presidi schiavi
noi ci vediamo allora aspetta per
comando sta qua ti volevo dire anche
un'altra cosa
grazie per avermi invitato prego bella
ragazzi sono divertito
[Musica]